je viens courbet m'a beaucoup déçu non
mais arrêtent leurs yeux c'est que c'est
notre copain je les trouvais pas dire ça
je les trouvais figé j'ai trouvé mou
j'ai trouvé que les sujets d'être noyé
au ton incisif mais ces réfugiés où le
connaît elle son gadget ridicule d'
interrompre les reportages au milieu on
dirait que breaking news génère est-ce
que vous avez aimé julien combes et hier
dans capital dit nous oui ou non vient
seulement il donne son avis on a gros
sur la vidéo de gilles voilà je vais
vous montrer regardez à quoi ressemble
et capitale avec les anciens
présentateurs regard du prix capital sur
m6 c'est déjà trente bougies soufflées
premier présentateur du magazine sur
l'économie emmanuel chain qui dès 1988
décrypte les tendances de l'époque
bonsoir c'est le mot à la mode internet
ni 3 emmanuel chain quitte la chaîne et
laisse la place à un jeune premier
guy lagache accrobranche parachute
ascensionnel trampoline scooter des mers
les plages deviennent de plus en plus
des parcs d'attractions 2011 guy lagache
est remplacé par thomas sotto vive
capital bonsoir qui au bout de deux ans
seulement décide de se consacrer à sa
matinale sur europe 1 et passe le relais
à françois-xavier ménages un journaliste
dont on se souvient moins et pourtant il
était champion régional de retourner
caméra 4km précisément on croyait que le
secteur était plan-plan seulement deux
ans plus tard le jeune entrepreneur
bastien cadéac prend la relève et
continue de proposer des sujets
populaires sur l'économie des sujets
toujours énoncé par croire soleil
palmiers et sable femmes mais deux ans
semble être un contre on lorsqu'on anime
cette émission puisqu'il laisse
aujourd'hui son poste à julien courbet
bonsoir à tous je suis vraiment très
très heureux de vous retrouver à la tête
de ce magazine capital
carton lumière et il a fait une
interview dans le parisien julien il a
dit joe hogan 20% de moins sur m6 que
sur ces vite on m'a dit c'est temps pour
la présentation pour le de capital donc
j'ai dit oui je n'ai même pas discuter
je m'en fous quand je suis passé tf1
france 2 j'ai touché presque 50% de
moins si j'étais resté sur la une je
serai riche aujourd'hui on me proposait
un contrat mirobolant pour me retenir
l'argent n'a jamais été mon moteur et je
confirme que julien courbet je vous lis
voilà il a il gagne moins sur m6 que sur
ces mythes on va encore débat là dessus
avec ce qu'on pense les téléspectateurs
et vous redire et voilà vous en penser
puisque alors j'aime et je n'ai pas